um give me a crazy boozy story because
he's got [ __ ] the pool parties that
him in trouble were doing during the
pandemic look [ __ ] insane
every time he's on IG live his house is
just so [ __ ] huge
I I love the fact he made his kids walk
his property line when they [ __ ] up
boozy is like the most entertaining
rapper alive so I can only imagine that
you've been in some funny situations
with him can you share something very
funny he said
I'll pull up to his house early morning
or something and he he had come
downstairs that [ __ ] mean in the
morning he'd come downstairs all hot
looking
blow his way
he see me he'd just be also
what up cuz he'll be on some Cali [ __ ]
like he was like I'm gonna get my Cali
on I'm doing it right yeah what up he'd
be on and I'll be like look at this
[ __ ] man
so I got a lot of stories though like I
could I could go next time I interview
him I'm gonna have him do his Cali yeah
yeah you gotta have him do it he do it
cold I'm like yo I need you to I need
Cali Boosie right now
talk to me like you talked to spiffy in
the morning
for the first 10 minutes of the
interview yeah oh that's funny you're
gonna put it on
would you guys do with that flame would
you guys do a joint album
for show
we working on one actually
be working on one so that's gonna happen
that's gonna happen how many records in
we probably bought like six records in
we got a lot of records though but like
as far as ones we gonna use for our
joint project we bought six records in
so I still man well look I can't wait to
hear the album what's it called buried
emotions buried emotions yeah coming top
of the Year top of the Year by the time
you watch this it'll probably be
it's probably going to come out next
Friday
so a couple of weeks away yeah I'm
coming soon and I'm coming soon juice
coming juice coming clothes coming
album with Boosie coming
so much shows coming all kind of [ __ ]
coming bro I'm working
yes you are man well I appreciate you
pulling up hey we're gonna do a
freestyle too you picked a crazy beat so
there'll be a different YouTube video to
go watch that I can't wait to hear what
you got on Hit Em Up by Tupac what's up
time to hit him up there's only a pot
spiffy Luciano bootleg kept podcast